[Music]
hey what's up my name is samuel leeds
i'm standing here outside of the
property we've just had an offer
accepted
welcome to liv cox you're my business
partner are you excited
very excited so liv has not seen the
inside of this house yet
but you've put an offer forward and it
was accepted it's been accepted i know
let's go around let's go check it out so
this is the house
this is your first time here yes inside
inside i've been outside with liv right
liv knows this is about
formulas not feelings right so you're
buying this on formulas you've had
builders come out
done all your research what's your first
time here yeah so i hope you liked it
crazy that isn't it but an offering for
a property not been inside you've seen
the floor plans and everything yes so
this
is gonna be a bedroom right yeah this is
a bedroom so if we go
through here and this is gonna be all
these are gonna have on switching right
yes so so so they're gonna come in here
gonna have a bedroom with an ensuite
yeah and then then we go through here
come on
currently a three bed but we're
converting it to six bed
three bed two or six minutes that's how
you add value though absolutely
you're buying this now for how much one
six five so she's boiling for one six
five
turning it from a three bed into a six
bed yep six on sweet rooms
yeah that's the plan yeah that's the fun
the new value is gonna be about how much
worst case two nine five yeah best case
likely case
320 right so not only if you push the
value up significantly because it's
going to cost you it doesn't think
you're going to spend how much the bill
was created about 65. 65. so you're
buying it for 265
spending 65 on it that's oh sorry no you
bought it for
165 plus 65 so in total 230 yes
plus obviously a few fees and stuff but
then if it's worth
say 300 worst case yep times
point seven five you're going to pull
out two to five absolutely see good part
mostly money yeah so what's this room
gonna be liv
right so this is a communal bit right
living room kitchen so you've got one
bedroom there
communal bit here and if we go through
here hold on kitchen
lounge hangout nice big space
open great location what are the two
things you can't change when you buy a
house
location and size location size big size
good location
it sounds like a tv show it looks like a
mess though right
yeah that's the point because then you
can add the value up yeah absolutely
and you've been in property you've been
doing voluntary stuff for a little while
yeah
building your portfolio but this feels
different though this feels like my
first big
project what's your first brr yeah well
it is yeah yeah
it's exciting so i've been waiting so
long for the right project i saw this i
like the numbers
yeah that's the one now as well just to
be really clear you don't own this yet
no just had an offer accepted coming
around it so by the time people watch
this
you
is just different and everything's nice
and such a good location
yeah and it's so close to your house
yeah 20 minutes
manchester yeah i love it all right show
us upstairs
okay so this room feels a bit tiny and a
bit horrible
yes so we're going to take some space
from the bathroom there okay
it's going to become a bedroom and we're
going to have two more back there so
three bedrooms up here
all planned to be on suites okay so
there'll be a bedroom this will be a
bedroom with a bit of the ensuite yep
and then okay so one bedroom ensuite
let's see what's next and then through
here
yeah we have two more bedrooms
so this is one big nice
very ugly very ugly it's just white
inside
it is isn't it how hands on are you
gonna be i know you're really busy
world champion freestyle footballer bbc
presenter
how often are you going to be coming and
visiting how hands on japan i've been
pretty hands-on yeah i am busy so maybe
a hands-off experience would suit
like my career and everything but i'm
putting so much energy and time to
prophecy that i'm a control freak come
on i can't hand it off
this is my project cheers
but you know what though as well i think
that people haven't been so close to
home
yeah it makes sense yeah you sit by yeah
yeah
absolutely the builders won't be
snacking with you 20 minutes so i tell
you that no i'll be outside
yeah yeah yeah and then
through here to
the next bedroom okay
final bedroom six bedroom this one hold
on so far hold on
one downstairs two downstairs
three up here oh my bad two this is two
right yeah this is two
so they're gonna come in here yeah
little corridor down here
bedroom bedroom yeah boom shopping
question then all right once you've done
this here's the great thing you're going
to push the value right up
yeah buy it for 165. spend about 65 on
it
so you're going to push the value up but
with six ensuite rooms
in this area the rentability is really
good now you've chosen to go for a
little less when
before um housing association yeah talk
me through that
well so i could get about three thousand
pounds rent if i did it privately and
you know
then i got a management company it's not
gonna manage that myself i'm busy my
career is doing well
active income i'm investing property for
passive income so i don't want to spend
my time like managing a management
company
or you know the headaches of maintenance
voids like all of that i'm not about
it's a social housing it's like it's
like the best kept secret in property
isn't it it's like
perfect yeah it guarantees me the the
tenants no voids
maintenance i know my numbers i can work
things out perfectly
so yeah i am taking a little hit in the
rent but for that assurance i think it's
worth it
now look there's a chance i always say
never be at ease until you've got the
keys
there's a chance until full throw you
never know it could happen searches
could come back bad there could be an
issue
you have had builders look at it you've
got a structural engineer come around
and have a look at it and it seems all
sound structurally
it could fall through you've had a lot
of opportunities you being live cook
like everyone's stolen opportunities
your life i'm throwing opportunities
everyone said
why was it why did you choose to go for
this property what was it in particular
that means you go yes to this house
yeah i think location for one yeah i
think it's great like it's close to city
centre you've got transport
links it's just a nice area as well but
for two i just looked at the numbers
and like the social housing it's
something that i've wanted to do that
guaranteed rent yeah
and that cash flow cash flows nice and
by time of refinance i'm pulling most of
my money out anyway
it's a no-brainer to go for this okay
top tip for someone wanting to get into
property
go just do it too many people it's true
too many people they dabble around
they're like oh i want to get into
property i'll do it when i save this
much i'll do it when i do that
i'll do it when my career is at a stable
level no there will never
be the right time in fact the right time
is right now so get out there
educate yourself and make some moves
love it love it love it
love it so what do you think i love it
i mean it's a mess on the inside that's
what makes it beautiful it's a brr after
all
it needs a lot of work finding these
deals does not come
easily no we've actually got this off
market as well off market didn't even
make it to market
it's not what you know it's who you know
in fact it's not even who you know
sometimes it's who knows you
yes and being well branded like you're
really putting yourself
out there now on the property side yeah
and that's paying off already you're
getting one network
yes what do you like working with me on
the property side i love it is it i'm
learning every day yeah i absolutely
love it you know what you won't find
someone better to work with than liv
you know because here's the thing how
you do anything is how you do everything
so the fact that if you're winning in
one area you can win in
another transferable yeah yeah and you
know we all know liv's a winner right
with a football with a social media her
presenting
so i'm thinking she's starting to win in
properties let me help her take things
to a whole new level
do you like this deal though i like it
of course of course i do and we're
trying new strategies we're doing new
things yeah
raising the bar so um yeah hey guys if
you want to check out our instagram page
it is winning wealth uk winning wealth
uk we're doing big things
with big people winning wealth uk don't
forget to subscribe you can subscribe
right over liv's face
i look forward to seeing you guys next
[Music]
time